thank you
[Music]
okay this one's a pretty crazy one we're
just we gotta talk about it though
because I'm gonna do Coke float
it's uh it's major what happened to this
woman
um in Texas
there's this Vietnamese woman who went
to the bank she took out a pretty good
size chunk of money because she's
planning this trip to Vietnam with her
family so she takes about like four
thousand something dollars out
because she needs a cash money yeah she
leaves the bank and somebody follows her
from the bank for 24 miles oh no I heard
this kind of stuff happens all the time
yeah it does uh but not to this not to
this actual degree this is like crazy
she doesn't know anyone's farmer she
doesn't know she she ends up at a
shopping center where she's going to get
a few things that guy ends up uh
approaching her and uh basically just
knocks her over grabs all the stuff in
the in the market on yeah like in that
area uh she drops all her things he
tries to run off with what he thinks is
the envelope of money yeah ends up
that's not it so she grabs the real
envelope and tries to get away he sees
what she did and realizes oh I have the
wrong thing so he runs up to her and he
grabs her and body slams her to get it
out of her hands and uh she drops it he
picks it up he bounces he's still on the
loose she is now left
I think the doctors say a 50 chance of
ever walking normally again that's rough
it's insane we need to get TJ out there
and and then he lived through it and he
got back to walking again so maybe she
could
walk or two again yeah it's uh it's in
Houston by the way
that's so sad bro crazy
um yeah so there's he's still on the
loose still I checked today and they
still haven't found him and this
happened a couple days ago they'll find
him
oh you think they'll find him yeah
I hope so there's so many cameras and
[__] like that yeah was it in the market
he's got cash too like all right so it's
like the camera just shows they're at a
shopping center you know like a plaza
yeah and there's a it's on camera they
have it all recorded saw her at the bank
withdrawing that money or he just yeah
that's what it is oh so the camera on
the bank yeah if he's behind or
something right damn do you think people
just hang out at the bank because I know
that they do this at the casino all the
time guys are just scoping like how you
win
I think they definitely do it I've heard
multiple stories about like
um you know guy wins a jackpot and then
like on the way home guys follow and
then when they go into their garage like
they slip right under a [__] Judo
that's why I was so surprised that you
guys got out of the Casita with all that
money well I was being a paranoid [__]
anyway because like you know we walked
out with like 116 G's in a backpack
which is [__] cool but I have like
security or something I don't know you
probably don't give a [__] yeah I don't
know they didn't offer it they're not
gonna pay someone to [__] look after
you they're like [__] you I'm pretty
sure you can deposit I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure you can go up to them and be
like yo can I guess there's escort yeah
they'll escort you to your car but I was
with her and it's fine I'm six four and
a half like [__] yeah I wouldn't mess
with you honestly [__] 89 pounds like
a new break so like yeah I was like
we're Gucci another one was um Bart's
roommate or in the same house the the
triplex the middle house they like to go
to the casino a lot and some guys were
watching them and they they were doing a
professional job where like they had
cable guy outfits
yeah and then they came in and then they
were just ransacking his place when Bart
came home
damn yeah and he's like there's no way
those guys are
actual cable guys because I call all the
utilities Bart would do that
I'd be like some upstanding built cable
guys
I like the idea of discovering that and
you just go there's no way you guys are
actual cable guys you're way too jacked
for that you know what he did he um he
told this story multiple times but he
goes hi and he runs into his house grabs
his gun and as soon as he walks outside
they're already jumping over the fences
everything parked it no no the other
guys they saw him and they said Hi and
then he they just started bouncing wow
like leaving yeah they all started
popping fences all that stuff yeah
yeah it's sad because uh so the woman
who got paralyzed she's a single mother
of three that came here
uh she she lost her husband to cancer oh
oh why is this story getting crazier you
know and so uh she explained that
um wait doesn't Texas have the death
penalty
but they even though they do have it
they haven't they haven't used it oh
what's the point it's been forever since
they've actually like it's very rare and
it's been a long time what's the point
of having a guillotine if you're just
gonna let it rot I don't think they use
goats I think you can actually be
sentenced to death and just never reach
the yeah that's stupid yeah that's
stupid
I don't know what that's the that's a
[__] load of money too it costs a ton
yeah it costs a ton to keep people on
death it's so cheaper to just kill them
but yeah they're saying that um that she
needs constant care to go to the
bathroom and everything now that she
can't like move and the doctor said 50
chance again if a miracle happens great
if not that's just gonna be her life I
think she's gonna be able to walk yeah
yeah and I think there's been there's a
GoFundMe there's a GoFundMe that's more
than recovered that amount of money but
I mean still like because 50 percent
that's not that's not that bad
50 what I've I usually don't hear fifty
percent chance yeah yeah I hear like
it's good odds yeah this is the kids are
older though I mean yeah yeah it's
better than toddlers how many monies is
this again four grand all that [__] for
four years four grand yeah I know
imagine that and imagine her bills bro
but that's a that's a nice pot for a
robber like you know like it's not a lot
of money but for for a quick snatch and
grab but that's crazy to think that body
Slammers really someone could just be
behind you in line at the bank and they
could just be like uh tailing you and
and kind of just scoping out your every
move and nothing you can't do anything
about it you can't be suspicious and
profile somebody and go like hey I know
what you're doing man yeah no but you
can be observant right like and I'm not
saying this lady did anything wrong or
whatever but like yeah when you dude I
am a weirdo like when I was taking the
boys money to [__] Red Rock I'm
clutching that [__] in my pocket with
both hands I'm like yeah I'm like
[__] I don't know I just I'm worried
about a phone in my pocket or anything
yeah like I'm just a weirdo head on a
swivel when I'm cash like that there's
risk I'm like a weirdo yeah yeah there's
some old ladies that like have so much
tunnel vision that I'm like do you even
are you even on Earth right now like
you're walking yeah they're just walking
down the street and I'm like [__] look
around you be careful I don't think the
phones help you know yeah that's true
because it could be but it's like what
what about here's the thing that's kind
of a kind of a dicey thing it's like
what if you're you've been taught that
it's offensive to look at someone as if
they're a danger to you
that's another thing too I'd rather be
wrong and Prejudiced but still like
let's say that she did see the guy there
and she decided to go walk on the other
side of the street I think yeah it is I
think some people worry about that [__]
though they're like oh I don't be I
don't be racist people do yeah people do
worry about that they don't want to feel
like oh like [__] dude it's it's not but
it's about like your Vibes because if if
[__] Steve Urkel was walking down the
street you know clearly everyone should
run away because he's a weird pervert
but then like
he might just pull his dick out or
something weird yeah you don't know
because
no tendencies
that I think if you got cash on you
Four G's I know for a lot of people
that's not a lot but for most people
yeah so if you if you're walking on the
street you know you're holding money
like that and you have any suspicion at
all you got to protect yourself [__]
what anyone else thinks that's true
that's true yeah no you didn't she's uh
she just doesn't suspect that someone's
following her no not at all so that's
the long content at the at the at the
bank pulling that out waited for her to
be at the at the supermarket another
location yeah following her at the
supermarket dude I'll think people
follow me in my own neighborhood
definitely bro this doesn't show her
actually being slammed but like here's
the here's the interaction like right
before it happened
oh no
yeah oh man so that's where you grabs
the wrong one season oh no
bro he looks like a kid oh yeah yeah
sucks but did you see how close he got
to her before she really reacted yeah
like he got pretty he was walking yeah
but that but that's when the situational
awareness has to be was she looking down
where was she on on point you know but
that's it's so hard though it's hard
because you're not expecting that yeah
everybody you know you want to you think
that there's good people even at this
even at this proximity at this exact
proximity she's still kind of just like
she's trying to do my life
doesn't know you know what I mean
because usually what people do is we're
walking
they move out to the side you go to one
side the other person goes the other
side but of course like what can you
really you know well it's tough bro it's
already done but you're carrying that
much cash and and you're by yourself he
looks like a team yeah he looks like
it's not it's hard enough to be a
Twitter commenter too exactly she should
have known this father right I'm
carrying that much cash are you kidding
me who the [__] are we like and how
often do we walk
people that close it's pretty oh it's
often all the time yeah and the fact
that it was the envelope thing he
probably wouldn't have slammed her if he
got it like there's so many factors with
it yeah but she shouldn't have Dove for
the envelope it's like come on
when it happens like it's bang bang you
don't know what's going on you can't
predetermine you're the best you try to
grab the [__] and run but he [__]
ran after her you know at that point
it's like what are you gonna do if
everyone can do perfect moves in a state
of [__] emergency right did I tell
you guys that um when I was a kid I
actually met the guy who was um
handcuffed to Oswald
when Oswald got shot whoa yeah where'd
you meet him in my kindergarten class he
came in and you don't forget something
like that it's crazy yeah why would he
go there dude Fairfax Virginia and he um
he was this girl named Kate in my class
he was like her Grandpa and like he
would come and he he told us about the
whole thing and he one of the
kindergarteners yes it's crazy but one
of the best things about it so he's the
guy in the yellow so you see that
picture of the Oswald Good Charlotte
okay [__] God damn and then you see the
guy next to him like like dressed like
Dick Tracy yeah that's this that's his
cat so then he was saying that people
were [__] on him because they say
that he pulled Oswald into the bullet in
the right way that got him seriously but
exactly it's like this kind of [__] it's
like Twitter commenters [__] that
was in the [__] 90s bro yeah but he's
like yeah I got to deal with people
being like yeah you made sure that he
died didn't you and he's like what the
[__] I'm handcuffed for the guy I don't
even know he's about to get shot yeah
yeah yeah look you can see me in the
photo he's like he's like what the [__]
is going on my job was to just take him
to court yeah exactly shut up like that
they do they and they think they know
everything because they're looking at
something oh they know in the situation
yeah yeah it's hard to say Obviously
what or if there's even anything to say
about what have been different here but
it's just super unfortunate it's super
unfortunate that every step of the way I
mean you really are just at the mercy of
whatever crazy person you know
yeah so hope hopefully she fully
recovers and when she does there's a
really really generous GoFundMe that has
raised massive amounts for her I think
the last time I checked it was already
200k and that was a long time ago
to the Moon I hope she gets here I hope
she puts it all in whoop
foreign